Selena Gomez living her best life
singing some Ariana Grande tunes and get
this Ari reposted it with a sweet
message it's a very exciting thing for
us
[Music]
the clip posted to Tick Tock by indie
rock band girlpool shows Selena and her
Pals seemingly enjoying an Italian
dinner but when Ari's track break up
with your girlfriend I'm bored comes on
they did what they do best sing
it didn't take long for Ari to see the
clip she reposted it to her Instagram
story and wrote Cuties are you kidding
she also tagged Selena and added love
you oh my goodness yeah it's amazing
fans immediately flooded the comments on
Tick Tock pointing out Selena's
impressive delivery of the fast lyrics
and some seem to think it could be a
hint that a collab between the pop stars
is in the works let's work on
manifesting that good I love it Selena
has been serving her fans some pretty
epic content on Tick Tock lately like
when her younger sister Gracie totally
trolled her over her well less than
Stellar social media skills you
embarrassed me I just deleted the whole
time
because see this is where it's at
Snapchat is where wait what
Snapchat
from one family member to another here's
Selena's Grandpa totally crushing it in
the gym
but if lip dubbing is more your thing
Selena's got plenty of that to offer too
I got some blue going on
[Music]
I don't know I like a little edge and a
little pop in my hair so I wanted to add
something different especially for the
team boat party
so you're telling me that you can read
his astrological birth chart but you
can't read the red flags
sis why do bad things happen to sexy
people
I'm too sexy for this but the triple
threat isn't only winning on social
media she's also gearing up for the
release of her new Hulu series only
murders in the building dropping August
31st
we're gonna go down there and look
around for Clues if you want to come
do I want to break into a dead guy's
apartment and go through all his
sounds like an afternoon Selena is a
consistent Queen so you know how this
goes she took things to where else Tick
Tock and shared this vid with her
co-stars Steve Martin and Martin Short
hey Steve should people watch our show
[Laughter]
laughs
foreign